اهلا ومرحبا بكم في لقاء فرنس 24
سو سيروس فرنسي
جميع الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه بما فيها
الفرنسيه كانت على خطا عندما توقعت
هزيمتنا امام الروس خلال ثلاثه او خمسه او
سبعه ايام لقد اثبتنا للجميع استحاله ذلك
وبان الامور لن تجري كذلك كم بعدها بدات
بعض البلدان بمساعدتنا قليلا الان ومع
انهيار اسطوره ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم
كان انهيار الجليد تحت الشمس اخذنا نشهد
زياده كل اسبوع في عدد البلدان المساعده
لنا
كيف ترى تطورات الوضع على مدى الاسابيع
والاشهر القادمه
باخطائهم وهذائهم وبالتالي سيقومون بكل ما
في وسعهم لتغيير مجرى هذه الحرب نحن على
علم بتحضيراتهم ونجهز مقاومتنا ونعرف
المواقع التي سيركزون عليها هجماتهم ونحضر
انفسنا لذلك واستطيع ان اؤكد بانه سيتم
حسب نهايه هذه الحرب في ساحات المعارك
ما هي افضل السيناريوهات الممكنه وما هي
اسواها
الحرب فن الانتصار بالنسبه لنا يعني
العوده الى حدود عام 1991 لا نريد اراضي
الغير ولا النعطي اراضينا لاحد
ناكر دور في القتال وسنبذل قصار جهدنا
لاستعاده اراضينا حتى حدود عام 1991 اما
فيما يتعلق بجميع الافكار الاخرى التي
بدات بعض الدول بتطرحها مثل منح بوتين بعض
الضمانات او التوصل الى اتفاق معه من اجل
التفادي استفزازه فهي كلها افكار غير
مقبوله بتاتا بالنسبه لنا
بكميات كبيره من الاسلحه منذ شهر اذار
مارس فكانت الامور كلها قد حسمت الان
فكلما حصلنا على الاسلحه بشكل اسرع كل ما
كان حل هذه المشكله اسره اقول هنا لاولائك
الذين يعتقدون بامكانيه الاتفاق مع نظام
بروتين الفاسيه منذ ذلك ليس امرا واقعيا
بشكل واستطيع هنا ان يعطي مثالا من
التاريخ الحديث في عام 2008 وبعد الاحداث
التي شهدتها جورجيا شارك رئيس الفرنسيه ان
ذلك في المناقشات بين جورج وبروتين الذين
تواصل الارتفاع ولكن بروتين لم يحترم اي
كلمه من هذا الارتفاع طيب لا يمكن ابرام
اتفاق مع شخص لا يحترمه كلمته
اما بالنسبه للجدول الزمني الامر يتعلق
بامدادات الاسلحه ولكن هناك عوامل اخرى
ايضا بطبعه الحال مدى ستبدا العمليه التي
ستفضي الى نهايه روسيا وتفكها انها مساله
وقت فقط
وهذا الوقت سيكون قصيرا من الناحيه
التاريخيه ولا ذنب لنا في ذلك ان انهيار
روسيا هو بسبب بوتين وتفضي جميع الافعال
التي ارتكبها في هذا البلد منذ 23 عاما
الى تفكك الاتحاد الروسي انه حفار قبر
الاتحاد الروسي
وحتى البلدان العظمى لا يمكنها فرد
ارادتها وشروطها على اراضي بلدان الاخرى
ناخذ مثال للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي خرجت من فيتنام عندما ادركت بانه لا
يمكن ان تتصل عسكريه باي شكل من الاشكال
لقد ارتكنت الى الحياه وغادرتنا على روسي
ان تفعل شيء نفسها وكل ما سارعت بالخروج
من اوكرانيا كلما كانت لديها فرصه للبقاء
والاستمراء بصوره مرضيه الى حد ما
اسمه
ذلك لم يقال بوضوح ولكن يبدو ان البعض في
الغرب
يفضلونا ان تدوم الحرب لفتره طويله في
اوكرانيا على ان يعتري الذعر الذره بوتين
فيضغط على الزر الاحمر لاطلاق الحرب
النوويه
يعتقدون بانها طريقه جيده في العمل نعم
الحق في ابداء تلك الاراء ولكن لا ينبغي
لاحد ان يخاف من بوتين فاذا بدات بالخوف
وتملكك الخوف هذا يعني بانك مهزوم مسبقا
وستخسر حتما اذا اذنت للخوف والهلع
وان اخافه
النوويه هو بكل بساطه امر غير مقبول
ولكن لا ينبغي ابدا الخوف من بوتين فهو لن
يكبس على الزر النووي ابدا انه جبان
فحسبروس
انت متاكد من ذلك
كبير من ممثلي الاستخبارات هنا في هذه
القاعه للحديث عن الاوضاع وتطوراتها وكلهم
كانوا على يقينا باننا سنزم
فاوضحت لهم بان ذلك مستحيل
باننا نفهم الرؤوس جيدا جدا ونعرف كيف
يفكرون ويتصرفون في الاوضاع المختلفه وان
لا سمح الله قرر بروتين اتخاذ هكذا قرار
فسيكون ذلك نهايه روسيا في اقل من ساعه
واحده ولن يكون لروسيا وجود والامر لن
يحتاج حتى الى رد النووي لانه بكل بساطه
سيدمر وجميع العاقلين في روسيا يعرفون ذلك
جيدا جدا بوتين لن يكبس على زر النووي لن
يفعل ذلك
العالم
يبدو ان لديهم افكار انتحاريه مثل
النازيين عند نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حين انتحر عدد من القياديين
الالمان الا ترى ان الرؤوس بمثل هذه
الافكار الانتحاريه وبنتهاكيهم لسلاح
النووي سيشكلون خطرا كبيرا
هل كبسه هتلر على زر النووي كلها ولكن
هتلاقي لم يكن يمتلك سلاح النوويه
باستخدام هذا السلاح لن يتركوا بوتين يكبس
على زر النووي هذا لن يحدث تذكر ذلك جيدا
هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى ونظرا للاوضاع
المزعجه للجيش الروسي فان مثل هذا
الانفجار قد يصيب اماكن تواجد القوات
الروسيه نفسها فنحن نشهد اصلا ما يحدث مع
الصواريخ التي يطلقونها على اراضينا ولكن
بعضها يسقط في الاراضي الروسيه انهم
يحاولون اخفاء ذلك ولكننا على علم ذلك في
مناطق
فولفوغاد سعر توب وكريسكا
هل تعتقد انه اوكرانيا لديها الحق ويتوجه
عليها استهداف اهداف في روسيا وهل شركاؤكم
الغربي
انت بتقولي الرئيس السيسي
ان شبه جزيره القرم هي ارضنا ونحن نقاتل
من اجلها ومناطق دونيتك ولوغانيتك هي
ارضنا ونحن نقاتل ايضا من اجلها نقطه
وانتهى الموضوع ولكن في منطقه في روسيا
هناك اسلحه تستخدم لقتل اطفالنا علينا
تدمير تلك الاسلحه ليسحب من هناك تلك
الاسلحه التي تقتل الاطفالنا عندها سنتوقف
من جانبنا
لقد اشارت الى جوكانزك وانت شخصيا
هلا تزال بتواصل مع الناس هناك هناك
كنت رئيسا لبلديه لوغانستان
جميعا
وهذا لا يمنعني ان اكون وطنيا
وهناك الك هنا مثلي الذين ما زاله هناك
ويساعدوننا من اجل الانتصار في هذه الحرب
او ادهشك على مدى الاشهر لاحدى العشر
الماضيه منذ الغزو في 24 فبراير الماضي
بل جاءت الاحداث لتؤكد على عظمه شعبنا كنت
واثقا اصلا قبل الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
ولكن وبعد هذا تاريخ بلغت هذه الثقه اعلى
المستويات
انه سينبغي طردوا بلدنا ارهابيا من مجلس
الامن التابعه للامم المتحده وحرماينه من
سلاحه النووي ولكن كيف يمكن القيام بذلك
وما هي الاليه المطلوبه
في هذا العالم على العالم ان يدرك بانه ان
كانت هناك دوله ارهابيه فلا يجب ان يكون
لها مكان في مجلس الامن الدولي على الاقل
خلال هذه الفتره
في الواقع ما الذي كان ينبغي بالاحرى
القيام به منذ اندلاع الحرب في ال 24 من
فبراير كان ينبغي تعليق عضويه روسيا في
مجلس الامن الدولي على الاقل طيله فتره
الحرب ولا كان ذلك امرا عادلا تماما بدلا
غمض العينين والادعاء بانه لم يحدث اي شيء
والاستمرار في حياه عاديه ان بروتين لا
يحترم القواعد ولا يحترموا اي اتفاق دولي
العالم يريد فعلا التعايش معه حسب الاصول
والقواعد ولكن ذلك لم يفللح عندما تلعب
الشطرنج عليك احترام القواعد المتعلقه
بتحريك الحصان او البيدق على سبيل المثال
وعندما تلعب الشطرنج مع بوتين يقوم برمي
كل القطاع دفعه واحده ويقول بانه الف هذا
ما يحدث الان
الرئيس
انه يبد الذهاب الى الامم المتحده في 24
فبراير القادم هل هذا لكي يطالب بطرد
روسيا من مجلس الامن
بذلك اتحدث هنا عن البلدان المتحضره اما
البلدان التي لا تهتم سوى بالمال وبما
يمكن ان تحصل عليه من الموارد الروسيه
فيجب اعلان ذلك صراحه امام العالم اي بان
الديمقراطيه والحريه والنظام العالمي
القائم على القواعد كلها قضايا لم تعد
مهمه وذات صله وبانه علينا ان نعيش وفقا
لقواعد اخرى علينا
الديمقراطيا حره
الافراد عناصر الاساسيه للديمقراطيه او ان
ندعم الارهابيين الذين من شانهم ان يقرروا
في اي لحظه ان يدمر هذا البلد او ذاك
قائلين بان ذلك يروح لهم شكرا جزيلا على
قبولك لدعواتنا وشكرا ومع اعزائي
المشاهدين على متابعتكم الاخبار تتواصلوا
على فرانس 24